we had a very big party here at home we
invited 30 people to a brexit party we
had a sing-along and I dressed up as
Patania in a helmet saucepan on my head
with ice cream cones on the top and we
had a lot of fun I didn't think it was
going to happen and neither did anybody
who came to the party which that was
what was so interesting as well as young
people are concerned I think there's
nothing to fear and fight in fact I
think they have a lot to gain from all
this what you have to remember is that
the elder generation and I'm one of
those have a great deal more knowledge
of history and of what's happened since
the war it's hard to tell young people
the way things could be they probably
won't believe you but but only time will
tell
I'm one of those people where I see the
glass half full rather than half empty
and I see this is a great opportunity
there will be some problems it won't be
easy and I'm very sorry that some people
feel upset but it was a democratic vote
and it's it's the new world we're going
to live